finally before we go i was very
intrigued by the story that came out
over the weekend about the new england
patriots resolving the grievances that
had been filed by antonio brown
and aaron hernandez
to the tune of creating seven million
dollars in cap space this year
and someone smarter than me pointed out
the reality that those grievances got
resolved
after
the cam newton contract became official
and the thinking is
that during the entire camp negotiation
however long it lasted
chances are didn't just come together in
a day or two
that for an extended period of time
newton and the patriots were talking
and the patriots said this is what we
can pay you look at our salary cap it's
not like we can give you anything more
this is all we can do
1.05 million dollar base salary veteran
minimum yeah we'll guarantee half of it
yeah we'll give you 700 000 in per game
roster bonuses yeah we'll work out this
incentive package 5.75 million dollars
that basically requires him to be the
league mvp and the super bowl mvp to get
it
but that's all we can do we just don't
have the cap space look here's look
here here here's our we'll be completely
transparent here's where we are we have
we don't have the cap space
and then after the deal is done they
pick up seven million dollars in cap
space look
just to tie the two ends of this edition
of pftpm together
look at how washington is handling
its name change how it's bungling its
way through it and look at what the
patriots did strategically to get cam
newton at the best possible contract
they could
and then
clearing up seven million dollars in cap
space after the ink was dry in his
contract
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things
and functional teams do functional
things
and that may be one of the reasons why
the washington franchise under 20 years
of ownership
by daniel schneider haven't had a whole
lot of success on the football field
maybe this new name whenever it comes
out will be the first step
toward the team turning it around but i
have a feeling as long as snyder's the
owner fans are gonna be waiting and
waiting
and waiting some more
for
uh the ability to feel like they did
between 1982 and 1991 when they won
three super bowl championships that's it
for monday's pft pm we'll continue to
monitor and report on all developments
in the national football
leagueprofootballtalk.com
and we'll do this again tomorrow
everybody have a great day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports